the decision came as a blow to
jehovosonaro the former right-wing
president remains a strong political
figure among Brazil's conservatives but
has been banned from running for public
office during the next eight years
[Music]
today I was dealt a stab in the back I
was made ineligible because I was
accused of abusing my power but the real
stab in the back was dealt to Brazil's
democracy Brazil's top electoral Court
ruled that bolsonaro abused his power as
president last July when he told foreign
ambassadors that Brazil's voting system
could be easily rigged despite offering
no evidence his unfounded claims were
broadcast on state television just three
months before election day
bolsonaro's lawyer argued that his
client had simply made use of his
freedom of speech to voice his doubts
and wasn't trying to undermine Brazil's
democracy we will appeal to the Supreme
Court he said but those arguments were
rejected by five of the seven judges
hearing the case
freedom of expression is not freedom of
aggression it is not the legitimization
of this information it is not an attack
on Democracy may be unable to run for
public office until 2030 but he is not
giving up on his political career he
says he will use his popularity to help
his Liberal Party in next year's
Municipal elections and he's already
traveling across Brazil to reach out to
voters
bolsonaro's supporters are painting him
as a victim of political
persecutionero's popularity will grow
and he will continue to be the standard
bearer of the values of the right like
family tradition we are counting on him
to elect almost a third of Brazil's
Mayors in next year's Municipal
elections increasing our presence in
National politics whether he is still
popular a year from now remains to be
seen Monica Al Jazeera Rio de Janeiro
still ahead on Al Jazeera